it could have happened at anybody but it
didn't it happened us a new band is
gonna be something nobody's ever seen
before
oh my god those are my pants but they
look so much better on me we gotta run
away a toothed plumber
an old man was just play it color Bansi
they say you're gonna be a rock star
what do you think
[Music]
holy [ __ ] we want to knock people on
their asses and we've got to give him a
show I'm talking like a stadium show in
the club's the fans that die for some
anarchy so let's give it to
[Applause]
I work for Elektra Records you guys like
a record Jin
[Applause]
I had managed the scorpions Bon Jovi
skid-row
kiss but I have never been through what
motley could put
I am sick and tired of not having any
fun everything's upside-down and
flip-floppy
loudly crew no strangers to
controversies Neal was charged with
vehicular manslaughter Tommy Lee and
Heather Locklear have separated it's a
degenerative bone disease nikki sixx has
overdosed I know it's like amazing but I
believe in us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
you